we're going to get to the corona virus
pandemic in just a minute but first tens
of millions of people are bracing for
dangerous winds today after deadly
storms hit the south on Easter Sunday
leaving at least 18 dead parts of Monroe
Louisiana were just devastated by a
suspected tornado that tore through that
city Anthony and the damage continued
Gale as the storms moved east Jesse
Mitchell is in Chatsworth Georgia north
of Atlanta where a tornado killed five
people overnight Jesse what's it looking
like on the ground there now
good morning Anthony the people of
Georgia were already dealing with this
deadly pandemic ordered to stay at home
now some of them have no home here in
Chatsworth you can see the path of the
storm behind me rip the roof off of this
apartment building there's a car under
this tree right here the woman in this
apartment said that she did get an alert
on her phone which she is grateful for
because it may have saved her life
unfortunately five more died not far
from here with another here in Georgia
and the damage extends much farther than
that further west in Mississippi at
least 11 were killed and one in Arkansas
the destruction made maintaining social
distancing hard for those in Mississippi
as they were forced into a shelter with
other displaced residents and take a
look at some of the damage in Monroe
Louisiana Louisiana and Mississippi are
already under coronavirus states of
emergency now the governor's in those
two states declared another state of
emergency because of the weather all
told the National Weather Service says
there were about 40 reported tornadoes
across just about every southern state
overnight and it doesn't stop there
today wind advisories extend up the East
Coast all the way to Massachusetts
making a tough situation even tougher
Tony as if the pandemic were not enough
we have to deal with the tornado if
Jesse thank you very much